i got a question for you who's picking
up the check tonight in a one-year
relationship
okay okay
not that that high-pitched voice was not
confident i did
miss the uk i will miss do you concur on
that
way to really sell him out lady jesus
keep relying on that one that's a real
alligator arms type [ __ ] like ah is it
i keep it in my shoe where do i keep
that wall of that yeah can i ask you did
you make a mess did you make a little
bit not a big but a little bit of a
mental note about that yes you just
brought it up in front of a room full of
strangers
that's as of a big as a medical note you
can get
this is all starting to make sense i
forgot what your question was but i just
read it again is it garbage to transport
a jet ski in a van
that's real can't find my wallet type
[ __ ] well almost
[Laughter]
please tell me it wasn't an uber or
something
are you an international spy by any
chance
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] man that's a tough look at
the docks when you're trying to get that
thing in the water in the lake yeah and
all of a sudden the jet ski just guns
out the back of a [ __ ] van
god damn you're ruining the carpets
holy [ __ ] is it did you pull this move
yesterday
[Applause]
buddy
hey miss you got a keeper
did you find a wallet has a van and a
jet ski
yeah no [ __ ] he's all right whose van
was it or is that your day-to-day wheels
you have a van
and a jet ski what year van we talking
99.
that's a pretty old van what you used to
jet ski
you have a 99 jet ski
what is it made of wood what the
[ __ ]
you're out there on the orca god damn
[Laughter]
we're gonna need a bigger jet ski
but hold on you have enough money you
have a regular car too right
it's a 1942
got a model t sitting in the driveway
what kind of car do you drive normally
ford folk a newer one right
it was actually the prototype
and you have the van for moving jet ski
and other trashy items purposes
did you just buy the jet ski you've had
it all this time
this has a real like
found jet ski type yeah
because you don't have a trailer you
don't have a hitch you don't have
anything you need for the jet ski
[Laughter]
where did you get the jet ski
a buddy exactly
i knew this wasn't you didn't walk into
a dealership and you're like hey i'll
take this one they're like cool we'll
[ __ ] but you're like no i got the van
out front
should i back up to the front door how
do you want to do this get give me two
guys turn it backward so you
how do you get it in
there a buddy
let me ask you this where were you
taking the jet ski from and where was it
going probably a swimming pool if i had
the guys
just doing donuts
trying to get my tick tock going
where'd you pick the jet ski up
oh you're taking it trip
i thought this was he's got a 99 jet ski
he doesn't have dock money yeah i
thought i thought this was a one-time
transfer
so you
so the jet ski was at your house you
loaded up in the van you went out to
the place you rode the jet ski and then
put the jet ski back in the van and
drove home
you're [ __ ] garbage
but
after all that work and i bet you that
van doesn't have air conditioning
how sweet was that ride that water what
you got on the water
wind blowing in your hair
i respect it dude one time for give it
up for nick that's [ __ ] vicky